it's a big thing about everything about
what our film was very much about
getting the story out and they're just
arriving on this remarkable story the
remarkable characters and in terms of I
always find it quite amusing today when
people say oh it's a great environmental
film because we didn't set out to make
an environmental film the other people
say it's a great social film we've got
Bolsheviks who love it because the
workers are getting together and we got
capitalists who love it because these
guys are creating a little new company
and we got religious people who love it
because about the Spirit of God and all
this other stuff but I think when we
were there it was very much just about
the story was really good and years ago
I learned about Kat Adora's and garbage
people who pick through garbage for
recyclables and had studied that a
little bit in this class I just kind of
sat in on for a laugh in 10 years ago I
knew that that project would be all the
rich food for thought that I think
wasteland generates